منذ الحقبه السوفيتي اعتبر الرئيس
الامريكي رونالدريا وناظره السوفيتي
ميخائيل كورباتشي في بيان مشترك انه لا
يمكن الانتصار في حرب نوويه ووقع معاهده
لخفض ترسانتيهما النوويتين نهج التوافق
على خفض الاسلحه النوويه تعزز في 2010
بتوقيع معاهده نيو ستارت بين الرئيس
الامريكي باراك اوباما ونظيره الروسي
انذاك
تكتسي المعاهده اهميتها من ان البلدين
يملكان نحو 90% من الرؤوس النوويه في
العالم وتنص على اقتصارها بالف وخمسمائه
وخمسين راسا لكل من البلدين وصواريخ بعيده
المدى وقاذفات القنابل بسبعمائه كحد اقصى
وهي ترسانه كفيله لتدبير الارض عده مرات
بحسب مختصين الحربيين في عهد دونالد ترامب
تعثرت المفاوضات لتجديد المعاهده لان
الرئيس الامريكي السابق كان يريد ان يقيد
ترسانه الصين ايضا مناخ وعدم ثقه بين
واشنطن وموسكو لدى وصول الى البيت الابيض
لم يمنع من
حتى عام 2026 لكن عمليات التفتيش
المتبادله للمواقع العسكريه تاثرت كثيرا
خلال سنوات الماضيه لم تجري عمليه التفتيش
خلال جائحه كوفيد وبعد ذلك توقفت لان
الروس لم يسمحوا بها اننا قد ندخل مرحله
اكثر عسكريه من العلاقات بين الولايات
المتحده وروسيا والعالم وروسيا والمعاهده
ربما لن تمنع ذلك حتى لو تم تجنيدها في
خطابه السنوي الاخير شدد فلاديمير بوتين
على انه يعلق المعاهده ولا ينسحب منها
وعادت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه للتاكيد على
انها ستواصل الالتزام بعدد الرؤوس النوويه
المحدده بموجب نيو ستارت بينما تعلق موسكو
المعاهده مع واشنطن توجه نظرها الى
الترسانه النوويه في القاره العجوز بمتر
ميدفيديف طالب صراحه بادراج الترسانه
النوويه لكل من بريطانيا وفرنسا في اي
اتفاقات مستقبليه للحد من انتشار الاسلحه
بين رو سيا والغرب